I just want to start with uh congrats on
being part of a show that has Taylor
sherrodden involved because everything
he touches turns to Gold
um can you sort of talk about what what
do you think it is about Taylor's
writing that resonates with so many
people well this is kind of a hybrid
show because
uh turbo did the pilot script
so it's kind of a great combination of
the Taylor ethos of the West and manly
man and danger and family but then you'd
have Terry who's got more of a New York
sensibility and you slide who brings
some humor to it so it's kind of an
interesting hybrid which works with the
fish out of water story exactly yeah I
was going to say that's one of the
things I found with the episodes is that
um it can be serious at times dead
serious and at other times it has a
really fun tone which is unusual for I
wasn't expecting that well I think in
any good show you if it's a drama you
would have comedic elements to it like
Sopranos could be hysterically funny
um and I think you'd want that you know
to have both those things you want
anything that's like life like life you
know I mean uh life is a
comedy that ends in a tragedy
the worst the worst part is that's dead
serious dead dead accurate
um I hate asking the generic question
but because no one has seen the show yet
what have you been like telling friends
and family about your character
um I just said she's a horse lady
because
um that's kind of like how we see her
from the beginning you know she really
likes horses but um as it progresses
there's more going on than we realize
there and there's maybe some plotting
going on that she's not what she seems
so it's like any great You Know Drama
it's not what you expect
yeah and uh Armand is some of the new uh
Dwight
for decades you know uh I used to work
for Dwight
um I ran the sports book for the
invernessy family that Dwight was a capo
in and it was always very intimidating
boss uh he was he was armin's boss and
uh
uh Armin is responsible for for a murder
that uh Dwight commits that sends him to
prison for 25 years and uh now I'm
living in Tulsa sort of hiding out there
um
my wife doesn't know anything about my
Mafia backgrounds and
um it all it all comes to Pieces when
Dwight suddenly unexpectedly shows up in
Tulsa one day and I can imagine he's
only there to kill me because I've been
looking over my shoulder for the last 19
years
um I don't realize that he's been exiled
there to set up a you know a crew there
into and to you know plant the flag for
the University's back home I think he's
there to kill me for soon to be fans of
the series what do you think they might
be surprised to learn about the actual
making of the show behind the scenes huh
behind the scenes was pretty much uh a
pleasure Cruise
I mean we had it was like a joy to be at
work every day I mean it was really I've
been on a gazillion show so you know so
was Dana obviously and like this one was
like really
the vibe was fantastic yeah I gotta say
it it was very well produced
um there was no wasted time you know
yeah because a lot of us would be in for
you know the way they shoot shows now is
there's two episode blocks so that you
could fly in for your two episodes and
then play out again so it was I was very
impressed by that I've never been on a
show that was so well produced in that
way yeah we did two at a time so with
the month one would be episode one and
two that was like in April with one
director with one director one crew and
then then the uh three four would be
block two and that would be a different
director a different uh not all
different crew but different you know
different GP you know different
department heads and stuff like that on
that note I need to stop I'm just gonna
say that uh this is going to be a huge
hit uh congrats and I mean I I know
um not even a question um have a
fantastic day thank you so much